one of the best things about the topic
the nature of proof
is that the knowledge and skills you
develop in it are very versatile which
is to say
you can apply everything you've learned
about uh
converses and contrapositives and logic
and deduction
you can apply them to almost anything
which is incredibly powerful to be able
to have
a skill which doesn't just apply to oh
this little category of problems
means that there's incredible power in
that technique or that strategy
but one of the worst things about the
topic the nature of proof is that the
knowledge and skills you develop in it
are incredibly versatile which means at
times you will encounter a question
that doesn't look familiar at all it's
not like oh i
know this question i just have to do
these four steps and out the answer pops
and that might be the feeling that
you're getting when you have a look at
this
question starting to read it you might
even think
do i know anything about this topic is
this something i'm supposed to be able
to do
the answer is yes you can with a little
bit of an introduction
so we're going to have a go at this it
is going to turn into a very classical
proof
by mathematical induction once we've set
it up and then also
just for a bonus i'm going to show you
another way to prove this result which
doesn't have anything to do with
induction
but it does contact it does interface
with some of the other mathematics
you've been learning
recently so let's dive in proved by
mathematical induction
that every set with n members has
2 to the n subsets and then they give
you
this hint which doesn't mean anything
until you can make sense of
what this sentence means uh what are we
talking about when we
mean sets subsets all that kind of thing
think all the way back to
series and sequences when we introduced
that topic to you the whole idea was
that
we had sequences you know a string of
numbers
in a particular order the order does
matter
and you can turn a sequence into a
series by
adding up everything in the sequence so
that's why the fibonacci sequence is
1 1 2 3 5 and so on it's not a series
but then we can talk about a geometric
series which is adding up you know
a bunch of terms which have a common
ratio now that's how you go from a
sequence
to a series you add uh all of the terms
to go from a sequence to a set
it's still the same idea you still have
a collection of objects but what you
take out is the sequential nature of
it which is to say one one two three
five if i just like put all those
numbers into a bag and jumbled them up
you wouldn't know what order which one
was first and which one was last
uh well there is no lust that's an
infinite sequence bad example
but in a set the whole idea is that
we've jumbled them up we don't really
care
about the order so the typical
sort of textbook definition is a set is
a collection
of unordered objects in this case
they're using the word members
so if you have a set that has n members
in it
what is a subset well the easiest way to
explain what a subset is
is to show you some of them so suppose i
had
a set with two members start off nice
and simple and i'm going to call those
members
a and b what is a subset well a subset
is the different sets i can make within
the members of this set so for example
this whole set uh i'm just going to call
it with my
set notation here open brace a comma
b that's the whole set including all of
its
elements it's members but i can actually
make little like selections within this
set and we call those
subsets because they sit within this one
so for
example i could say a
the set that includes a that's a subset
of
a and b b is also
its own subset i could say for example
that
a and b that's another subset within
that it just
includes everything and then there's one
last
sneaky subset that's hiding which is
there is always a subset that doesn't
include
any of the members that you've got there
we call it the empty set
right so if i sort of tabulate this i
already wrote down
a comma b that's kind of the set that
includes everything
then i had individually a uh
as a set and then b as a set
and then weirdly the set which has
nothing in it the empty set
is just some curly braces and as the
name suggests there's nothing in them
right
how many subsets are there and the
answer is there are four which is two
squared so
what i've shown is that you know when
you've got two members you've got two
squared
subsets and i could do this again if i
had to think about what would happen if
i introduced a third
now in fact a third member i should say
now that's actually going to be my segue
into trying to understand
what is this hint that they've given us
and then how can we use it
to assemble our proof by induction
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
uh when we read this it says when a new
member is added to a k
member set then every subset of the
resulting
k plus 1 member set either contains or
does not contain the new number all
right
i'm going to use the same trick that i
used before to understand this very
vague
uh abstract algebraic language i'm just
going to put some numbers
on here so i'm imagining if k were two
right
so when a new member is added to a
two-member set
this is my two-member set right here a
and b then every subset of the resulting
three member set either contains or does
not contain
the new member so i'm going to introduce
a new member into this set i guess using
a and b i'm just going to write the next
one as
c and i want to think about the fact
that well now i've got a whole bunch of
extra new subsets that are available to
me right
how many will they include well if this
result is true
i've got three members in this set so i
should expect to find two to the power
of three
eight subsets now hopefully the first
thing you notice
is that i've got these uh these four
subsets that i got from before
and all four of these subsets are
included in
the first uh in this new set right
all of the subsets of my two members
subset
member set are part of my three-member
set okay but i can then add on more
um starting with the fact that either
these new sets either contain or do not
contain
c so all of these subsets here they
don't contain c
and so what i can do is i can say i can
add on
a set that corresponds to all four of
these sets
just by adding c to that set so let's
actually start
from uh from the top here right we had a
and b as one of our sets what happens
when i add
c to that i guess i needed some more
colors here let's go with
say blue that's going to be a b and c
so this would be the subset that i get
there's there's that what happens when i
add c to that one in fact i'll even
write it down
i'll write it down here so i'm going to
have a and then b
and then c then i'm going in order i'm
going to have the a
set including c as well so that's going
to look something like
i'm so drastic we're going to run out of
colors uh a and c
like that so i'm gonna write this
underneath
a comma c i've also got just adding
along i've got the b
set and add that to c as well so
that would look like this so i'm going
to get
b comma c and then the last set
the last subset i should say is going to
be the empty set the empty subset
plus c so that's just going to be let's
do it in black cause you better see that
this one right here okay so that's going
to be
c and hopefully you can convince
yourself by looking through
maybe you draw up a three-member set
yourself and try and think of
is there any subset that i'm missing and
i can know
conclusively because i've sort of done
this by exhaustion right
i've got the original four and then i've
got this new four which gives me the two
cube to the eight
subsets that i was hoping for so this is
what we're trying to understand
uh obviously this doesn't constitute a
proof because i'm just looking at
examples here
and i'm trying to prove this for for any
n and that's a positive integer
so how do i do this by induction well
now that you understand the whole
sets members subsets thing let's start
our regular old proof
by induction let's uh first
start off with our base case
what is the base case now i think i
might have said positive integers before
which is a bit sneaky
i really should have said you can have
as we have just demonstrated with the
empty set
you can have a set with zero members so
i guess that means that
n equals zero would be the first time
where this works
so i'm going to test the n equals zero
case right
how many subsets are there if i have
no members in my set and i would say the
subsets are just the empty set
there's nothing else that i can use
to make a new subset can i confirm the
result that i'm trying to prove here for
the base case the answer is yes i can
2 to the power of 0 that's my 2 to the
power of n that equals
1 which is indeed the number of subsets
that i found
just above so therefore i can say yes
this is true
for the base case namely n equals 0.
okay wonderful now we then progress we
want to say well
what happens when we assume that this
actually works
for some arbitrary value of k
of m so which i'm going to call k so i'm
going to say i'm going to assume true
for n equals k and
i guess what would that look like i i
want to sort of do something like this
right i want to list out
uh list out all of the sets um subsets i
should say
and then i want to make a statement
about those subsets in relation to
this thing i'm trying to prove right so
what would it look like to list these
things out
i guess i would say the subsets
of our k member
set so i want to list out all of the
subsets in a systematic way just like i
did up here just to make sure i don't
miss
any right so where should i begin well i
guess
the first subset i thought about was the
subset with everything in it right
so what would that look like for us well
if my subset has k
members in it i guess it would start off
with
a and then b and then c and it would go
all the way up to
k right so this has um
all of the members or k of them in the
set that's one of the subsets
what would the next one down have the
next row right
well i went from having say two members
down to one
down to zero and this would be three
down to two down to one right
so what i would have is not the subset
with all of the numbers in it
but the subset with everything except
for one right so for example
i'd still start off with a and b and c
but then
i would end at the the last one i was
going to write k
minus 1 which i could um but i could
just as easily just to keep things like
sort of sensible for us i could say it
ends at j
that's the term before k right that's
one of the subsets which has
uh k minus one members in it and then
there's other ones right um for example
maybe i leave off
a i could write it as b and then c
and then d and that goes up to k
i could leave out b instead so that
would be a
and then c and then d all the way up to
k and this actually goes on forever
right well not quite forever but until
i've got all of them there
and i don't know how many there are
because i don't know how many
members there are it's an arbitrary k
then i would keep on going down
at some point just like i did up here i
would end up with
the sets which have two members in them
so you know it might be a and b
then i suppose we could make that's a
really bad curly brace
a and c a
and d i could of course combine you know
dot
dot i could combine b with all of the
other ones so i've already got a
and b i could have b and c
b and d and so on
and then lastly you know i guess the
final one would be j
and k right and then
i'm almost at the end there i have all
of the subsets which have just one
member in them so there's a
there's b there's c i think my curly
braces are progressively getting worse
and then i would end with k and then
lastly
this is the all of the subsets with one
member in it
i would complete with the subset that
has no members in it the empty
set okay so here are all my subsets of
the k member set
all of them i've tried to try to list
them out with lots of copious
ellipses now what i can say is from the
inductive hypothesis or the inductive
hypothesis
is that the total number of
subsets total number should write
is
2 to the n but in this case we've got n
equals k so
2 to the power of k this this is my
assumption
that if i take all the subsets of this k
member set
all of these total them up count them i
should end up with 2 to the k which was
indeed what we verified over here
and we did it for the empty set as well
okay so
there is my n equals k assumption how do
i prove this for n equals k
plus one so prove for
n equals k plus one um what we're
required to prove
is that uh k plus one
member set
has two to the power of k plus one
subsets okay so
here i'm going to try and very directly
use uh
the hint that i was given up above right
when i add this
new k plus one member okay the subsets
will either
not contain that new k plus one member
which is to say
um it's inclusive of all of these
they're all going to be included
um or there's going to be um
it does contain right so either i don't
contain them which i've already counted
by assumption that's 2 to the k or it
does include it which means i need to
sort of
form that list right so i can say
proof the subset
of or the subsets i'm just going to say
the subsets
include
subsets with
the next term along which i'm going to
call it l
i guess i'm going to say maybe i'll put
that here new member
is l just so i can refer to it there's
going to be the subsets
that include subsets with
out l and with
l right now by assumption here's me
using the
inductive hypothesis right by assumption
the subsets or the total number of
subsets
without l i have already counted
because those are the ones up to k
um is 2 to the power of k
right then i can say the subsets
with l what would they actually look
like well the subsets
with l
would be and what i can do is i can just
create um this copy here sorry this is a
little bit cheap right
and i'm going to just adjust each one
ever so slightly to include
l in it so we start with this one here
the big one
let's call this comma l
and then i've got the first one and i'm
going to add l to all the other ones
as well so i can put l into this one
i can put l into this one and i hope
what you're seeing here is once i've
gone through this entire
process how many subsets
will i have i'm going to get a bit lazy
i'm just going to put this up here comma
l
comma l comma l and so on
ah a and l
b and l c now k n l and then i will move
this guy for the empty set
the empty set and then plus l how many
sets are there going to be or subsets
rather
within this list and the answer is
exactly the same number that you started
with
because you haven't added extra sets
you've just taken those existing sets
and stuck l inside right so i can say
there are and this is again from the
assumption
there are two to the k subsets including
l because that's how i generated
all of these subsets therefore
the total number of subsets
will include the ones without
l that's 2 to the k the ones with l
that's also 2 to the k that's 2
times 2 to the k which is 2 to the k
plus 1 by index laws as
required so
i hope that made sense of how we were
going to use the structure of induction
move from the k
to the k plus one step um and i'm using
this hint
to try and divide up you know this k
plus one
member set how do i connect it to the
k-member set and the answer is to say
the k-member says literally half of the
number of subsets
that you get